[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen süßer lief
welt ich bin hier in österreich und zwar
in kärnten im süden österreichs und hier
besuche ich heute denn alles darauf es
wirklich super schön hier ich bin schon
seit ein paar minuten da und habe mich
auch sofort verliebt ich bin auf den hof
gekommen durch die mädels vom intersport
die haben so vom hof geschwärmt und was
der hof im interspar zu tun hat und was
ich hier so alles erleben erfahrt ihr in
diesem video
wie es der zufall so wollte ihr habt auf
einem hof kinder nämlich anna hannes
thomas und die kleine karte und die
katze diana diana die große ist eine
ganz treue zuschauerin von mir und
freunden hat sie noch sex geht ein traum
für mich in erfüllung und anna ich kann
sagen für mich geht auch ein traum
ich war noch nie für richtig schön in
den bergen und jetzt darfst du mich
immer alles zeigen und hey super los
geht's
[Musik]
hier hinter mir seht ihr auch schon das
schöne haus da ist natürlich auch das
restaurant da kann man drinnen und
draußen essen und wir haben jetzt weil
wir eben diese österreich tour machen
oben ein kleines zimmer gemietet also
eine wohnung und können weil es auch
übernachten und da kann man wirklich
auch wirklich toll zur ruhe kommen also
man kann das auch für mehrere tage für
eine woche buchen und einfach das ganze
jahr über herkommen und hier ist es
wirklich so schön man kann wandern man
kann einfach die natur genießen oder
einfach mal runterkommen und so machen
wir das wir sind jetzt zwar nur einen
tag da aber auf jeden fall werden wir
mal in den sommerferien oder den
herbstferien mit der familie herkommen
weil für samira ist es hat echt eine
richtig tolle oase also die leds vorhin
aus dem auto gestiegen sofort zu den
tieren gerannt hat sich gleich mit den
kindern gut verstanden und hier muss man
wirklich nicht sehr auf sie aufpassen da
passiert alles in der natur
zur familie kleinschmidt gehören papa
die mama sonja tochter anna die söhne
hannes und thomas und das nesthäkchen
partie sehr schick und habe die ganze
familie zusammen also ihr habt ihr das
restaurant deshalb freitag bis sonntag
und dann habt ihr die tollen
ferienwohnungen die wir später noch
zeigen und was macht euren hof noch aus
wir sind direktvermarkter das heißt wir
versuchen einfach alles was rund um den
hof wächst so produkten zu verarbeiten
unter anderem stellen wir säfte liköre
marmeladen chutneys und teigwaren hier
also backwaren nudeln chips und du auch
mal ganz lässige hühner sind unsere
mitarbeiter gehen
und die liegen eben die eier die werden
und so lud verarbeiten herstellung ist
die nudeln und das knabbergebäck was ist
beim interspar gibt
sehr schön auch wieder einfach ein
unternehmen was euch unterstützt und ihr
dann lokal die sachen vertreiben könnte
da können wir die fleißigen helfern
anschauen
mein nudeln und teigwaren da gibt's ja
viele dieses herstellen aber die meisten
benutzten eben nicht freilandeier und
hier haben wir einfach die hühner direkt
vor ort die leben hier wirklich richtig
schön und schauen wir uns mal anders
also wenn man eine vorstellung von brio
und freilandhühner dann glaube ich so
ich glaube der mir richtig viel spaß
ganz gewöhnlich uns fällt das gar nicht
auf es wird immer so ist ich stelle mir
dann immerhin und charlene 4 und beim
fressen zu schaffen oder den schienen
das ist mir so was beruhigend ist es ist
so so monoton aber so
das beruhigt helfer das erdet
[Musik]
freiland huhn und was freilandhaltung
heiß kommt wieder hoch und mein kopf ist
das auge aus blickt der monaten berg für
sich
schatzi sinnvoll zahmen die machen mich
glücklich guckte sich sonst ganz hoch
filmen wie die hühner hochlaufen frei
aber für euch werfen teuer
[Musik]
anna boos richtig schön und die ziegen
was hast du mit den beiden auf sich ja
noch ganz viele andere ziegen will ja
aber von ihnen ist die mutter gestorben
und dann hab ich die gefüttert und ihnen
da bin ich dann innerhalb sechs
aufgestanden
vor der schule nach und tappen will ich
mich aufgewärmt und wo hast du drei
monate lang mit der milchflasche
aufgezogen wahrscheinlich hätten sie es
sonst gar nicht geschafft ohne mama gar
nicht so schön so richtige ziegen mama
bist du jetzt noch und wie hast du die
dann gekauft colada und die andere ist
braun ich brownie und roulade so süß
oder ich glaube das ist es was man liebt
und ich sind auch ganz zahm kann ja
verstehen urwald die so geliebt hast und
sie großgezogen es nicht schön einfach
toll was ist deine aufgabe hier
ich würde da die katzen die katzen und
wer füttert die häschen dass du thomas
otter guck mal gleich mal was du machst
du was der thomas macht und dann gehen
wir noch zu mama und papa in den
kräutergarten und dann schauen uns
bleiben und die zimmer an
[Musik]
und anna hat dann eure eigenen kräuter
stehen und die benutzer dann
wahrscheinlich auch für eure eigenen
produkte gab nudeln für die saucen für
alles mögliche für ängste sehr schön
etwas ganz besonderes ja ich habe mir
eine eigene tor ablenkt forcola pflanze
tag x
[Musik]
dass die cola plan heimlich nach
wahnsinn was kann man daraus machen
cola zero und jetzt was erfrischend ist
wenn sommer ja das glaube ich
ach richtig schön dann gehen wir glaube
ich mal nach drinnen da könnt ihr mir
eure produkte zeigen den bauern lagen
nehmen dein papa mit theater papa darf
sich auch gerne wissen ausruhen
[Musik]
hätte jetzt haben hier eine kleine
auswahl von eurem produkt mit
rausgenommen aber ihr habt ihr wirklich
alles also von nudel angefangen malawi
um wir machen relativ viel ist die not
ist ein böser hauptprodukt natürlich
aber wir machen wir laden liköre säfte
schnäpse chutneys festus wir versuchen
also das mal alle produkte die am und
und entwurf boxen zum teil baumanns und
erlerntes wildkräutern dass man das
einfach veredeln und vermarkten dass er
gewisse wertschöpfung am beruf wäre es
uns mit lebensweg und ihr könnt dann im
prinzip auch fast alleine schon von
eurem hof leben
wir leben hier viele versorgen
tatsächlich ist das ist uns gelungen wir
haben am anfang selber nicht an das
geglaubt wir haben den ruf gekauft weil
er wie zehn jahren noch so jung wie alt
war damals die denkkraft mit der 20 g20
war und dann schon so eine große
entscheidung getroffen hat es war
einfach so illusionen für uns wir
wollten das einfach wir wollten immer
mehr kinder haben und wir wollten das
thema in einer natur in einer umgebung
aufwachsen wo man das vermitteln kann
und glaube einfach dass es wichtig ist
dass dieses wissen erhalten bleiben mit
dem verspeist das jetzt sage uns hat
tolle kooperation wurden wir sind jetzt
mittlerweile das thema ordner von
interspar und das ist wirklich für uns
ein sehr wichtiger abnehmer aber mein
ständiger konstante abnahme und das ist
für uns natürlich auch wichtig also
wirklich tragen einfach jeden tag heuer
und wir müssen sie jeden tag verarbeiten
und dann brauchen wir einfach an treuen
kunden sind die kinder sind dabei die
kinder center mittendrin anna hilft euch
schon fleißig mit
und die wachsen 11 uhr mit dem auf- und
so riesig samani
wir wollten das bewusst so klein halten
dass man das als familienbetrieb führen
ja sagen wir wichtig dass man mit der
familie vereinbaren kann ich mich fragen
ja auch immer alle wie ich es mit der
familie vereinbar und ich denke bei euch
kraft wie könnt ihr das alles managen
ihr habt irgendwie geht den hof und die
ganzen tiere aber alle helfen mit das
muss man einfach mit freude machen wenn
es einen spaß macht dann schafft man das
ja irgendwie aber wir haben schon sehr
sehr lange
kg
[Musik]
sich einfach mal ausspannen komplexen
das genießen das zu uns kommen ganz
unterschiedliche leute kommen familien
das kommando war einfach man wolle jetzt
managertypen die einfach nur zeit suchen
und die finden sie bei uns handy
weglegen einfach mal ausschalten genau
einfach in den wald näher und damit am
flügel und beim singen zu hören dass ich
glaube das gibt einem schon muss und
jetzt kommt was am gewinnspiel zum
gewinnen gibt es einmal ein richtig
tolles paket von euren produkten was
hier zusammengestellt wurde und die die
und sonja waren so lieb und haben gesagt
komm wir schenken den zuschauern noch
zwei übernachtungen
das heißt ihr könnt mit etwas glück und
wenn ihr gleich die frage richtig
beantwortet auch zwei übernachtungen
hier gewinnen wir können das internet
nur die zwei übernachtungen hier bleiben
oder auch einfach verlängern und den
rest einfach selber übernehmen
ok-chef los wie heißt die frage die
frage heißt wie heißt die marktgemeinde
in der waldhof liegt erhält vielleicht
noch ein bisschen nachdem wir ein
zweisprachiges gebiet sind hat die
argumente natürlich auch einen
slowenischen namen und der hessische
lissner kappler und von eckhard jetzt
gegen den deutschen post also am besten
gleich ein bissle recherchieren und in
die kommentare schreiben und mit etwas
glück in ihren entweder dieses päckchen
oder die zwei übernachtungen hier
gewinnen
[Musik]
echt total schade dass wir nur einen tag
hier sein konnten
denn unsere österreich tour geht ja noch
ein bisschen weiter aber hier im alter
hof was wirklich wunderschön also ich
habe glaube ich noch nie so einen
schönen ort wie hier gesehen vor allem
die familie hat mich total beeindruckt
die die uns und wir machen das richtig
toll mit ihren eigenen produkten sind
vier wunderbare kinder sogar an hat die
elfjährige tochter macht es schon toll
der die ziegen hier groß gezogen und man
sieht einfach wie viel liebe auf diesem
hof steckt man kann hier wirklich als
familie seine zeit verbringen
das werden wir mit sicherheit auch
nochmal machen und auch samira das
nächste mal mitnehmen der gerade schule
und konnte nicht mit und dann rein
formale woche entspannen hier unsere
zeit genießen die ruhe genießen
man kann hier auch action erleben
wirklich im umkreis im kern ist es
sowieso wunderschön und hier auf dem hof
einfach im traum
also ich hab hühner gesehen ich habe
hier ziegen geführt hat wir haben sie
gestreichelt kleine häschen auf dem arm
getragen und für kinder und für uns
erwachsene ist es wirklich ein paradies
also wirklich ein paradies und im
prinzip kann man als kunde zu hause auch
solche höfe unterstützen indem man zum
beispiel im supermarkt so wie jetzt beim
interspar einfach ausschau hält und
schaut wo sind denn die lokalen helden
wo sind local heroes und dann vielleicht
nicht immer einfach zu den großen marken
greifen sondern auch die kleinen
unternehmen somit den allgäuer hof
unterstützen
ich hoffe ihr hattet viel spaß bei
diesem video und hat super viel spaß
gemacht von ella wirklich fast den
ganzen tag nichts gesehen die spielt
hier in aller seelenruhe mit ihrer neuen
freundin kathi wir kommen auf jeden fall
wieder vorbei ich bedanke mich noch mal
ganz herzlich für euch für die
gastfreundschaft und zwar ein ganz ganz
schöner tag her
ich genieße noch ein bisschen die ruhe
vor dem urlaub wieder zu bekommen
[Musik]
die hellen gern nicht die dunkle nicht
die schwarzen was ist das schwarze l
hier gegen kaká
[Musik]